he's an American hip hop recording
artist from Detroit Michigan he sound
with good music in 2007 Def Jam in 2008
and rock nation in 2014 his album dark
sky paradise earned him his first
number-one on the Billboard 200
he's Big Sean and here are his top ten
rules for success one thing people need
is inspiration you know they need a lot
of things but they definitely need that
too you know inspiration can you know it
can like create anything inspiration can
create the best ideas you could create
the million dollar ideas that could
create the billion dollar ideas that
could create leaders you know
inspiration can change everything so I
feel like people need that man you just
got to stay true to yourself you know
never try to follow the trends that's
when you get lost in the sauce man you
got it do what you feel man and be
creative and don't be scared to be
yourself and always keep that faith you
know I've been in the darkest times of
my life man where I didn't know what was
gonna happen I was flat broke anything
you could think of man I've been through
it and like you know you got to be
strong enough to make it through and it
just makes it that much sweeter when
everything starts going right when I was
in the third grade and my teacher was
like nah this is some funny [ __ ] though
radio what they want to be and it was
like lawyers doctors this and I was like
I want to be a rapper signed at Def Jam
I said that in third grade right my
teacher was like oh just like oh no and
[ __ ] right same teacher wants me to come
back and speak at mus don't do that [ __ ]
my point is man that whatever you're
doing like man you make sure you follow
your heart and do what you want to do
man actually you don't want to be 56
years old which you woulda coulda
shoulda did something like that's the
best advice I could give you and I
promise you man if you follow your heart
and always keep that faith they'll lead
you to your pot of gold to the lead you
to your million dollars whatever you
want in life I promise man
I learned something different from
everybody you know it's just like it all
depends on like yeah I just learned you
know always follow your heart always be
real straight up don't take no you know
what I'm saying
common just calming somebody who like no
matter what coming has going on with one
thing you always have something else
going on like he'll always be like if
he's not acting right then he's making
music if he's not making music he's he's
always finding some ways to brand
himself away from music - and I respect
that
you're on him saying he's more than just
a rapper Aries are he's he's like
all-around businessman and I respect
that about coming you know those little
things you learn from guys like that
that you hang around and you know you
take you take a little tips in a platter
so risk there is no chance to evolve in
progress without taking risk I feel like
it's the necessary element to self
development you know like it's the key
to living life to the fullest risk
according to Webster is the chance of
injury damage loss the failure of your
expectations but I realized that it's
also the opportunity to learn and gain a
fulfillment of your desires and dreams
when I think of risk or just what risk
means I feel like I might think of being
afraid or oh really
risk is a way to overcome what you fear
you can be afraid to risk something or
everything because you don't want to
lose what you have because you're afraid
you may fail or think you can't handle
it or whatever the case you'll spend so
much energy and time trying to keep what
you have instead of progressing into
something new everything changes
nothing stays the same forever nothing
from business it's a personal everything
in between
I realize that you can't be afraid a lot
of us aren't all the way satisfied but
are scared to lose security and what we
do have like I might not be able to get
a better job or a better partner etc or
even as bad as prison is you know there
are people who don't want to leave
because they're afraid of what's on the
outside or being able to succeed the
number one thing I got to remind myself
sometimes and remember is that life is
here
not to survive but to live it up you
know to expand to grow when you settle
for what's familiar or safe is because
we forget that God is our security God
is creating artists and that's the only
security you know you could try and find
security in people and jobs or anything
man-made but there's no point because
everything is designed to change
including you most people who have
successfully taken risk and succeeded
have failed to but the point is you
learn from every lesson you learn from
every risk change is always exciting
it's always exciting when you know God
is involved the world is designed for
change
don't ever be afraid to take risks how
did you make this perseverance to push
through all of this I don't know man I
just did you know I just that people man
my grandma you know my grandma is one of
the biggest inspirations to my mom you
know my my desire to want to give
everybody around me a better life the
desire to want to live a better life man
that's just that's my whole motivation
man coming from Detroit city people
don't make it out the west side of the
truth you're not believing just like
spreading that that love you know I'm
saying that Google just like good vibes
like I live like a hippie you know what
I'm saying
I believe in just like you know it's
feeling great letting people know like
hi I made it happen for myself and am
making it happen
one thing I used to be a victim of is
like when I was in the studio with Kanye
jay-z all these people and they would do
a verse to a song I would try and do a
verse like they would you know what I'm
saying and the message it just wasn't me
it wasn't me than sound right so I just
realize that you have to stay in your
own lane yeah just do what you do and go
all the way with you man don't look that
my definition of success I think success
is more unlike any motion than it is you
know what you get physically like
successes and how much money you make it
isn't like you know it's just about like
what you accomplished how you feel at
the end of it all you know that success
and I feel like I've been successful in
some ways but I'm still you know hungry
for that success that I want and you
know i'ma get it we'll make it happen
I'm hung out 25 and you know look at
people who I consider successful in
their you know way older you know what
I'm saying
I got a lot of time to get it right and
I'm learning you know so I think success
is definitely about an emotional more
than 100 million dollars or anything
yeah
amount of interview quite a lot of
people now so same question
that's one of the best answers really
yeah success is like yeah you can be
successful as people who are riches the
richest people in the world couple you
could be the richest person in the world
and I'd be successful you know those
people who have the most money who got
the most problems too and are the
unhappiest as people who are taking a
bus every day and you know who got a
family and they're the happiest ever you
know so I think success isn't measured
by how much money you make or a big as
you know the house you want is measured
by how you feel imagination how many
people you know I mean for real no made
it got on nobody from my city Detroit
hell no I ain't know him you know I
don't know nobody who did I know I made
it my point to be the one who made it
the one people knew before I made it to
show everybody it was real I grew up
watching biggie mace I wanted a Rollie
like pot fill me all the money like
masterpiece stunting like the Big Tymers
I wanted to pop champagne you feel me I
want to put my crew on have a label like
Rockefeller put the city on you know I
started off young spitting rapping hey
turn me up trying to be a role model
trying to be son I knew I was gonna make
it
I just st. know how
my mom taught me early on this world is
what you make it you create your own
environment it all starts with a vision
but you can imagine you can create I
came with middle class I really have a
shitty spare and I haven't no money to
spare I had to work for new clothes gas
money I always wanted to get my mom when
she wanted you know cars Benz houses
whatever I didn't have it but I could
see it in my head
I could feel the energy of you build a
house up on that ass that's an a state
that's the masked race say yay say yay
don't we do this every day take some
songs about talk like just out payday I
don't even know if that makes sense but
it always made sense to me it was all
real to me my imagination was real to me
the people used to tell me I was wasting
my time said it wouldn't work out where
the people in any hash they am nothing
it wasn't till after meeting the people
I grew up to getting a chance to meet my
idols work with him I realized they
believe what I believe imagining it
changing the world changing their world
a lot of people could imagine but
wouldn't believe it I couldn't fathom me
not me I believe I had imagination thank
you guys so much for watching we made
this video because Patrick vane asked us
to now if you have a famous entrepreneur
you'd like Evan to make a video of leave
it in the comments below and we will
make him do it I also love to know which
of Big Sean's top 10 rules meant the
most to you leave it in the comments
below and we're going to join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon